hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to lunacy st. roads now this
is a demo to an ongoing lead developed
game it's a horror game so you don't
know what this game is all about but
this game looked fantastic from what I
saw and judging by what I see now I'm
inclined to agree with so I don't know
what to do okay I thought I saw a shadow
moving across we're all but I don't know
what to do and I don't know what this
game wants for me so I'm just gonna try
to do it as best as I can I have a
flashlight or do I just need to yes I
have my answer thank you for that now
let me clear the poop out of my pants
and carry on with my adventure ah lovely
is this the lunacy of which I was spoken
about hi always my favorite thing ooh
you should have read this huh Oh flasher
light oh boy
hey sweetie just to let you know I won't
be coming home till midnight if you come
home earlier please leave the lights on
and go to sleep as soon as you can
why would I need to leave the lights on
that's a waste of power my mom should
have come for this sooner mom I hate
this house mom full of demons
mouki every door is also locked ah
that's what I did I opened dive I got
scared by a banister I got scared by
goddamn railing
enough of at your rumbly wombly bubbly
[ __ ]
whoo finally an open door who'd it
funked it in this house in my house okay
so far so goo so far so I don't know
what to do hi who's home
see you mom I can't figure out how to do
it on the line
[Music]
hey how can I help you
Ernie Bobby's your Girl Scout cookies
right you just have fun wandering around
in my yard which seems to be the
backyard for some reason cuz it's fenced
in I don't understand that but I'm just
gonna accept it may no likey this oh
you're open hey railing you have any
opinions about this all happening over
here you say January 7 1905 I found a
door hidden behind the cabinet in a room
after searching the whole damn place I
found the key on the top shelf in one of
the tea cups I hesitated going inside
for a while I thought she might be there
I finally entered and I saw presence I
locked the door hit the key behind the
Nerds a very helpful thank you just may
be creeped out
you didn't actually do anything for me
okay alright how about that then I can
do that too I just don't feel like
participating in your adventure
ah yes ooh very dark and shadowy I don't
know what that says but that's some sort
of writing that's some sort of
Slenderman so that's the the thing that
you were talking about I said I don't
know how to unlock it cuz you said
something about a key and I don't know
where that is
get the key behind the behind the what
key behind them the keys got to be
behind something oh hello ah didn't be
neon tank thank you for the guiding hand
I'll take this key I suppose unlock
there so I suppose can I do that
oh not that one okay wait what did I
unlock then or what am I gonna unlock
cuz I'll read the note again door hidden
behind the cabinet in a room okay so
there's a cabinet here ah the decorum in
this place is just to die hello mother's
bedroom key ooh
audacious where's mother
all right well my mother doesn't mind me
intruding in a room still just as gloomy
in here as it is anywhere else
okay so there's is there something
behind this cabinet oh hello okay she is
gone I can't believe she's gone I
searched the whole house many times and
still nothing the stupid business trip I
should have stayed with her these few
days before our wedding I just don't
understand where she could be why the
wedding dress why is it the only thing
missing was she trying to do oh I don't
like that hi
ah that makes my blood boil you okay
right oh boy hey thank you
okay fine you know I'm okay with that
Oh what is that oh that's not good
that's not good oh hi I hate everything
about this but I'm a brave boy I'm gonna
face you please come at me bro come at
me boy baby breath come at me bro
yeah you lay but run do you stay over
there are you facing me now huh that
what you think you gonna be doing I will
have you know that I am a badass I'm
gonna stab you in your groaning throat I
will stab you in your eyes and then you
will die eat a dick in the goo well I'm
gonna fall the groaning then the hallway
stop it stop I don't want it I don't
want any of it
I don't want it who's banging was it out
here or is it somewhere else
what's with for blogging oh okay sure
yeah let's go with this one hello pal
the hall apartments
what you say don't do what don't hope
don't hump me mom is that oh hi okay
well what's up with your leg there okay
okay all right I guess that's okay I
guess it's all better now up here can I
hide in this hole oh hi hello I see you
there why are you there oh yeah sure
okay yeah I'll go down there how do I go
down there
well I don't like the look of this I
can't get in here oh it's full of blood
in there
Oh that'll wait oh that's heads you like
heads okay I like that about you that's
something that makes me
I'm gonna hide under my bed cuz I got
nothing better to do yeesh I don't think
this helped me in any way I don't think
this helped me at all
I don't know where I'm supposed to be
going what the heck is hey dad dad dick
dick dick dick dick I don't like this
[ __ ] man where am I supposed to go I
didn't press any buttons there that was
of your own volition hmm that sounds bad
should I go back in here visit my old
pal man okay no oh come on in no no no
no I'm going in I did not do that
ah good the mannequins gone my favorite
thing
[Applause]
oh you peaceable oh [ __ ] you my god
okay I gotta get back in there I guess
oh hi okay okay all right all right hey
hey hey hey
are they still down there well that's
open okay all right you know what I'm
down I'm down to clown I'll give it a go
I'll give it the old Gander with my
peepers hello twins love it my favorite
thing Oh Jay okay let's see we just
moved in there's still a couple boxes it
should be delivered by tomorrow later
that night as I was getting ready to go
sleep I heard a creepy scream coming
from outside I looked out the window
into the woods pretty sure I saw a tall
figure standing there I will guest her
up and told her what I had seen but when
we looked again it was gone
I guess it was very tired and needed
sleep immediately join our demons
okay let's just follow this logic here
[Music]
all right okay I don't know this music
come from over there but I'm assumed
that's not good I know hey you're open
now let's open the whole house up oh
good
paintings art art and music know what I
do
oh hi okay all right well you just come
on on meander and down I don't know how
to good way from you if you kill me I'm
gonna be very pious okay all right
[Music]
okay then Oh another key okay what is
the second of two keys that I haven't I
have no idea I don't know where they go
I don't know where they go I don't know
where these keys go weird oh okay
found a key for this that's good oh I
can't see her everything reminds me of
her everywhere I turn I feel her
presence it feels like she's still here
and watching me last night I couldn't
sleep I heard a loud knocking oh he's
coming from one of the walls you got
that right oh my god I gotta leave well
I gotta get out of here oh the music
stopped oh great oh good oh that sounds
great poppy okay the key which key to
what what are we talking okay okay
someone on the chandelier Oh someone is
on the chandelier I'm here oh boy that's
a fun sound these are all fun sounds
right oh why and where what the heck
what the heck
carry on oh hi hello that is a definite
yes oh all right okay all right okay all
right okay do I follow you that's not
good that's at that oh hi oh
and I'll do others are always good Frank
bride-to-be disappears Esther Dayton
mysteriously movie a few days before her
wedding her future husband was away on a
business trip after coming back too soon
to be wife was missing wedding dress
found nobody wait okay what does that
mean what does that mean
what does that mean bad oh that was good
that was good I mean the death was like
meal whatever and then I start all over
but that was good because it made things
were different slightly but different
this is a really good start to a horror
game and I hope to see more because this
was just a demo good stuff though lots
of detail lots of ambiance loved it I
was terrified to do more with the
mannequin actually don't I don't want it
but do more with the mannequin so thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know what you thought of this down
the comments below if you want to see a
full game of this also mention that in
the comments as well and thank you
everybody again for watching as always I
will see you
in the next video
[Music]